OK, les gars, on est arrivés devant l'appartement,
il y a Nams qui nous attend,
on va décharger les cartons et on est bons.
Boris, gare-toi là.
Il y a une place juste ici, tu te gares.
Je me gare pas là.
C'est à cause du créneau
que j'ai failli rater mon permis.
C'est même pas un créneau, ça.
Vas-y, gare-toi ici.
Tu as vu comment c'est dur?
Viens, on se gare là!On se gare là !
On est à 200 mètres.
Ça va être long.
Prends la vaisselle.
Boris!
Je vais t'aider.
Non, tu n'aides rien du tout. Garde le camion.
Touche à rien !
Tu n'es pas obligé de t'énerver comme ça.
Oh Nams, frérot, c'est comment?
Ça va ou quoi? Ça fait plaisir de te voir.
Hein?
- Carrément, le lait avant le chocolat?
- Tu es au téléphone.
Je monte et je redescends.
C'est bon?
Je ne peux pas.
Si tu mets le lait avant le chocolat,
c'est mort entre nous.
Oh, les gars, ça y est.
C'est le grand jour, le nouvel appart,
on va le découvrir ensemble.
Incroyable, je suis trop...
Oui, Akamz, ça va?
- Ça se passe?
- Je viens de démonter le micro-ondes, là.
Ça avance bien.
Le micro-ondes, ça ne se démonte pas,
ça se porte comme ça.
C'est plus facile en petits morceaux,
fais-moi confiance, aïe !
- Akamz, laisse le micro-ondes tran...
- Aïe, fait chier!
Allô?
- Aïe!
- Allô?
Purée Nams, franchement, tu es un bon.
Ça fait plaisir d'avoir des amis comme toi,
des amis game.
- Attends, viens, on fait une pause ou quoi.
- Quelle pause?
Ça fait deux kilos.
Là, c'est trop lourd.
J'ai une idée, au pire.
Si on prend les livres un par un comme ça,
tu vas voir, ça va aller beaucoup plus vite.
Attends, je ne l'avais jamais lu, celui-là.
J'avais lu celui d'avant, mais le dernier…
Tu es bête ou quoi?
Nams, je te le donne, le livre.
Aide-moi à ranger les cartons.
Nams, tu ne vas pas me laisser?
Pourquoi balancer cette peluche?
Je suis tout seul.
Il est vraiment trop lourd, le podcast.
Ça va, je ne te dérange pas trop?
Non, tranquille, t'inquiète.
Pose.
Vas-y, éclate-toi.
Ça ne marche pas, c'est bizarre.
C'est quoi tout ça, là?
Eh ben…
- Je peux savoir ce que tu fais là, toi?
- Moi, je… J'habite ici.
Vous faites quoi chez moi?
- Chez toi?
- Oui.
- Oui, chez moi, porte 17, bâtiment B.
Oui, c'est chez moi.
Bâtiment B, c'est en face, d'accord?
Ici, c'est le bâtiment C.
Ah oui, le bâtiment…
Il a un problème, ton pote, là?
- Oh !
- Il écoute un podcast.
- Pourquoi vous êtes agressif?
- Cassez-vous de là, allez.
- Vous êtes sûr que ce n'est pas chez moi?
- Non, ce n'est pas chez toi.
Grave, mon frère.
Mais qu'est-ce qu'il fait?
J'appelle le conseiller. Vas-y, c'est bon.
Allô?
Que se passe-t-il, Monsieur Belaïche?
Je me suis trompé de bâtiment,
il y a toutes mes affaires dehors.
Il y a Akamz qui a démonté ma fenêtre.
J'ai besoin d'aide.
Vous savez que sur l'application Check,
vous avez des réductions pour faire appel
à des déménageurs professionnels.
Franchement, je vous kiffe.
Merci.
Franchement, merci les gars,
vous êtes incroyables.
Vous êtes dans le top trois
de mes déménageurs préférés.
Allez, ciao!
En même temps, des déménageurs,
je n'en connais pas beaucoup, je ne connais qu'eux.
Tu es encore là? Je t'avais oublié.
Elle est claquée, laisse tomber.
Vas-y, mon reuf, tu peux le prendre avec toi?
Non.
Vas-y, je dois bouger de là. J'ai un petit date.
Tu t'es lavé les mains?
Non, pas encore.
Je me lave les mains dès que j'arrive au date.
Vas-y, on se tient au jus.
Bon, le principal,
c'est qu'il y a toutes les affaires.
On fait une visite?
Il n'y a pas de lumière. Oh non.
Je vous appelle parce qu'il n'y a pas d'électricité
dans l'appart, je crois.
Attendez, je regarde.
Votre contrat est bien activé.
Normalement,
tout est censé fonctionner correctement.
J'allume, mais il n'y a pas de lumière.
Vous êtes certain que ça ne vient pas de l'ampoule?
Il n'y a pas d'ampoule, en fait.
Dans ce cas-là, le problème est résolu.
Vous savez quoi? Je suis épuisé, je suis KO.
Donc, on peut s'appeler demain?
- Oui. Bonne nuit, Monsieur Belaïche.
- Merci, bonne nuit aussi, merci.
Bonne nuit, tout le monde!
Bienvenue dans le nouvel appart!